hello YouTube just loves in my friends
this is grunge in here
welcome to the 19th episode of dirty
chance tricks in this episode I am going
to show you a very tricky way to play
against an opening called sniper now no
matter you are d4 player or a 4 player
you should have a good replica against
this opening because from last 1 year or
so this opening get a tremendous
popularity specially at the club level
ok here white start with the d4 and
after the move g6 white play the movie 4
and after the move Bishop to g7 my
recommendation is you play the move
Knight to c3
now the pure sniper move here is sefa
and that we are going to look in detail
but before looking at it if you open in
place move such as d6 which likely to be
transposed into the park or the modern
defense then my only recommendation is
in my past I have created a lecture
called chest strap 5 against the park
and the modern defense where I
recommended a 150 attack which arises
after the mordor Bishop to e3 Queen to
d2 castle on the Queen side and then
white launched a devastation on black
ink side why are the move h4 h5 and I
think it's very fun and attacking way to
play against pork and the modern defense
ok c5 and this is where exactly many
black players get attracted because what
happens in the most of the scenario is
white play the move Knight to f3 and
then black continue with his initiative
I the move Queen to a finite to c6 and
putting a lot of pressure on this d4
pawn and black seize the initiative just
a lane the opening so this is exactly we
don't want here I am going to recommend
you certainly take this pawn and now
unlike my other daughters
trick video where we find the tactical
solutions Here I am recommending a very
greedy but a very sound approach by
white so what we are going to do is in
most of the lines we are going to hang
on to the spawn with a wonderful
position and even though let's say in
one or two lines where black caddy spawn
back white get tremendous attacking
compensation okay now just before we
start I like to show you a plan of
campaign by white so let's say black
continue over here with the Moon Knight
to c6 so for a time being black is
ignoring his material and try to develop
his pieces where here is the first step
what we are going to do is we play
Bishop to e3 so protecting the c5 pawn
here black continue with the move Queen
to e5 so it has a double hit on the
night so we are going to defend this
with the move Queen to d2
now black get another tempo with the
move Queen to b4 attacking p2 no problem
we are going to defend with the move
route to b1 and now the second important
part when black plays the move Knight to
f6 whenever this Knight develop on the
f6 you always going to support your
efore pawn with the move f3 so not only
supporting the pawn but we also stopping
Knight to g4 black castle on the Kings
side now the third important aspect most
of the cases you are going to develop
this Bishop on this d3 Square and black
here continue with the move rook to d8
right here continue with the move a3
hitting the Queen Queen to a5 and now
the typical developing move Knight to e2
and this is probably the setup you are
going to see in most of the scenario and
here is my vital point in order to free
up blacks Queen side piece development
black has to either move is D pawn or be
pawn and whenever it happens what we are
going to do is we are going to exchange
the spawn and remain a pawn up for the
rest of the game
so for example let's say here black
continue with the mu D Phi
why took this poll and after black
recapture and the castle not only white
is a clear point up but White has a
bishop pair and I seriously have a doubt
what compensation black is having can
you spot a one single compensation for
black well I am afraid I can't see it
okay before we move on I like you to put
this plan in your head and in most of
the scenario we are going to stick with
this plan stead of Knight to c6 let's
say what happens if you open in place 92
b6 well same story first we are going to
capture this Knight giving black a
double pawn now we are going to play the
move Knight to e2 so we are not allowing
black to [ __ ] of a pawns after Queen
to a5 we are going to play the move
Bishop to e3 protecting of a pawn after
rook to b8 we are going to protect again
with the moonroof to be one after Knight
to f6 second important point yup you
play the move f3 and after the castle
and we castle once again white emerge
with a clear-cut pawn up third move
Knight to f6 which hardly any black
player will consider because after the
movie fie black has to play Knight to g8
back as if we play Knight to h5 then
white will win the piece on the spot
okay so let's consider the one of the
main moves of the sniper that is either
Queen to a5 or bishop capture c3 now
Queen to a5 I have created a whole video
on this line where I recommended a very
tricky approached by a white that is
Bishop to d2 so if you haven't check out
my video which is known as chest trap 13
against the sniper then I do recommend
you check it where I have covered this
line in detail I will just give you a
sample line that what kind of fun right
can get in this line that is let's say
when queen capture the spawn then white
is going to play the move Knight to d5
and after the usual
such as Knight to f6 White has this
little Bishop to b4 so Queen has to
safeguard the c7 square the only square
left is Queen to c6 afterwards White has
this shocking move Bishop to b5 and
black queen is a goner only MU Queen
takes and after Knight to c7 we have
royal folk okay now let's consider the
one of the main move of the sniper that
is Bishop capture c3 and after pawn
captures this is where most of the
people get afraid thinking that oh why
it has this triple pawns on C file and
black is doing very good but what the
forgetting is where it has an extra pawn
and it's very hard to get this pawns as
I highlighted over here
Black has three different choices
amongst them Knight to f6 is probably
the most critical one but we should see
what happens a black plays other moves
so for example let's say black continue
with the move Knight to c6 I think this
is the probably the most harmless
variation here the first step
yes is Bishop to e3 protecting of a pawn
of a first target now black plays over
here Queen to a5 hitting the pawn the
second important point we play the move
Queen to d2 still protecting both the
balls now black continue with the move
Knight to f6 third important point yup
you play the move f3 now if black
castles are at this point then white
will simply play the move Bishop to d3
in Knight to e2 and remain a solid pawn
up so in this game black continues with
the move b6 so he likes to open up the
center immediately no matter white
continues with the capturing the pawn
and when black recaptured white find out
a amazing idea so what white has played
over here is Bishop to at six so not
only stopping black to castle on the
King side but White has a very sneaky
idea to play the move Bishop to g7
and nab the night and this is a very
model demonstration how to handle the
slides so here black continue with the
Moon Knight to e5
so his idea is to play the moon d5 no
matter white continue with the move
Bishop to d3 and after the move defy he
continued with the move Bishop to g7
hitting the rook hitting the knight
black plays rook to g8 but after Bishop
captures pawn captures Knight to e2 D
capture z4 Bishop captures efore rope to
a7 and castle on the Kings side not only
white emerge with pawn advantage but
black has lost his castle right now
let's look at the second critical reply
by a black that is Queen to e5 black is
attacking two pawns but here white has a
very amazing attacking reply that is
Queen to d4 so not only protecting the
pawns but white is hitting the rook so
black responses force black has to play
Knight to f6 and now you cannot play f3
because black has the move Knight to c6
so instead of that white has a better
move that is Queen to b4 hitting the
Queen now is this position few times in
my games and there are mainly three
replies tried by the black the first one
I want to look at is Queen to c7 which
is most harmless reply because here
white will execute his plan with no
problem so I continue with the MU f3
protecting my center my opponent
continue with the move Knight to c6
I played Queen to b3 so Queen is very
safe there
no problem my opponent castle on the
Kings side I protect my pawn with the
move Bishop to e3 and our same problem
for the black in order to free up his
Queen side he has to move beyond the D
pawn and hear my opponent continue with
them a group to d8 and after the move
Bishop to b3 he indeed played the move D
Phi but this is exactly white once
because after pawn captures rook
captures and Knight to e2
white emerge with clear pawn advantage
okay now what will happen if black plays
Knight to c6 well against this I'm
recommending you should capture this cui
and after Knight captures you just
consolidate your pawn with the move
Bishop to d3 well you can't play f3 but
in this situation your Bishop is not on
e3 so I think Bishop d3 is more accurate
okay the game continues with the move
castle on the Kings side I continue with
the move Knight to e2 and now my
opponent plays the move b6 I capture the
pawn my opponent recapture now this is
the recommendation by GM Ron in his foxy
opening he has only considered the move
Bishop to e3 saying that black has a
compensation after the moody file
well that's right but white is not
forced to play the move Bishop to e3
instead of that why it has a better move
that is Bishop to g5 so if allowed then
white is going to double the black pawn
and I don't find a single compensation
in this line and I can illustrate this
by showing one of my game here my
opponent continued with the move King to
g7 I continue with the rook to be one
hitting the b6 pawn my opponent played
Knight to c6 so he is counter attacking
my a to pawn
no matter I defend it with the moonlight
to c1 and now indeed the b6 pawn is
hanging so my opponent has to forcefully
play the Mook to b8 afterwards I simply
play the move f3 and it's a very hard
position for black because black is
clearly lagging plan and on top of
everything he is upon down the best
reply over here is d6
but after the move Bishop to e3 black is
about to lose his second pawn black
continue over here Knight to d7
protecting the pawn but just looking at
it would you be black at this position
not at all the simple reason is there is
no chance of developing this bishop and
all black pieces are doing is defending
and white is a steel pointer well after
few moves white is managed
in this game so that shows the potential
of this line the last move black and try
over here is Queen captures the only
thing black has done is to give us
healthy pawns on the Queen side
okay black and get his phone back after
Knight captures e4 but this is the case
where black get his phone back but wide
get a tremendous initiate and let's see
this the most forcing sequence over here
is Bishop to b2 hitting the rook and
kindly note Knight f6 is not possible
because if white wishes white can give
double pawn to the black so black plays
castle on the King side now white plays
Bishop to d3 hitting the night once
again so black plays defy protecting the
night and now the strong move Knight we
do so idea is to dislodge this night
with the moonlight to g3 or Knight to c3
here the black continue with the move
Knight to c6 hitting the b-pawn white
plays a3 and now black get desperate
with the movie file but I think he
totally underestimated that he is
lagging behind in development before I
move on I like you to pause this video
and find a continuation where white can
clearly press his initiative okay I hope
you find this motor that is f3 hitting
the night after night to f6 we are now
going to show the black who is the boss
over here so we play the move b5 hitting
the night and after Knight to d8 we play
the MU a 4 so white has get a tremendous
pace on the Queen side and after the
game continuation that is Knight to d6
hitting the c5 pawn white has this
amazing sequence that is Bishop captures
pawn captures c6 pawn captures pawn
captures Bishop to b6 and now the star
move Bishop to b4 and white has stamped
his extra pawn on the sixth rank of the
black
now a black players over here Knight to
c7 then Knight to d4 is a very strong
reply in this game black continue with
the move Knight to d8 but this is just
asking for it
white continue over here with the move
Knight to f4 hitting the d5 pawn and
it's funny they're black and our
defenders black continued with the Moody
four but after rook to d1 the second
point Falls and in fact the game okay
now it's time for look at the most
critical reply that is Knight to f6
against this I think the best reply over
here is you play the movie file
now if the knight goes back then the
Bishop III and we continue with our
usual plan so the only critical reply
over here is Knight to e4 so hitting two
spots and now if you play Queen to d4
over here then I think Queen too if I
can equalize for the black so instead of
that I'm recommending a very sneaky move
here that is Bishop to c4 so White has a
very simple threat that is Queen to defy
hitting two spots here a few replies has
been tried but the very obvious Knight
captures c3 is a blunder because of
Queen to f3 and black is going to lose a
piece you might think hang on Queen to
e5 but here is the answer that is Bishop
to d2 and that piece is going down black
and also play the move Knight caps C
file but after the move Knight to f3
black has to play very accurately now I
did this position in one game where my
opponent immediately castle on the King
side but instead of that if he plays
moves such as Knight to c6 or Queen to
e5 then I have covered those variation
in the pgl so kindly go through the pgl
okay
my opponent plays castle on the King
side I continue with the move Bishop to
b6 he played route to e 8 and now this
is the beauty about this line as this
epsilon square become
beaker I immediately jump on to attack
it with the move Knight to g5 so here
the force reply is e six and now another
beauty about this line that is Queen to
f3 and those dark squares are really
really weak again the black response is
force black has to play Queen to e7 and
now I simply cancel on the Kings side L
black as a hell of a job to my opponent
continuing with the move Knight to c6
hitting the fi I defend it with the move
to even now he played the move b6 so he
want to develop his Bishop on the b7 but
my reply is a very sneaky one I played
Queen to f4 and after the move Bishop to
b7 I give you a few minutes can you find
whites next reply okay I hope you find
this move that is boom ha ha ha
so this amazing sacrifice is likely
going to happen when you have a so much
attacking potential black doesn't have
much choices so black has to accept this
piece sacrifice afterwards the simple
but very effective
push up to G Phi and black is busted my
opponent try the MU apps exist and his
idea is to play the move Queen to f8 so
he thinks that he can escape very easily
after Queen check but what he missed is
my critical reply root 2 e 3 and now
that is lost kid so more or less over
here Queen to e5 is a most common move
well here white would love to play Queen
to d5 but then Queen to c3 is spoiling
over fun
so instead of that I am recommending a
stronger move that is 92 and now black
has three different choices the worst
one is Knight capture c3 because after
Queen to d2 like lose the piece and if
Queen captures C Phi
this point then the simplest is you play
Queen to d4 and this position believe it
or not but has a decisive advantage to
the white and let me show you how
so after Queen captures and pawn
captures what is threatening to play the
move f3 and trapping the knight
the only good reply over here is f6 no
matter we continue with the MU f3 and
after
Knight to g5 we can simply capture this
pawn after he captures and Knight to c3
not only black cannot castle on the King
side but why it has a severe threat of
Knight to be finite to defy which black
cannot prevent it so in this game black
continue with the move Knight to c6
but after Knight to d5 he is about to
lose the pawn in this game my opponent
was 2100 plus rated so he played the
Moon Knight to e6 and after Knight to f6
he thought that he can get his pawn back
after the MU King we have 7 which at
first sight looks very obvious because
your knight is attack and if you move
that night then your deep one will fall
but luckily for me I have amazing
tactics now before I move on I like you
to pause this video and find out a
continuation where white is completely
winning ok I hope you find this move
that is defy so hitting both the knights
and the cute point behind it if the King
captures this Knight
then after Bishop to b2 we are skewering
the king and rook Knight to d5 doesn't
stop it because after pawn captures
Knight we are going to get two pieces so
that was about Queen to c5 the final and
the most critical move is Knight
captures c5 but against this I'm
recommending you play the move Queen to
d5 so creating a pin and attacking f7 so
the force reply over here is e 6 if you
open and play is the move castle at this
point and this is a
under the simple reason is after Bishop
to at six hitting the rook and the MU e
6 White has this wonderful reply Queen
to f3 so not only we are hitting the
room but if the rook moves then Queen to
f6 leads to the checkmate so e 6 is
forced after this I am recommending you
play the move Queen to f3
so the typical theme in this line that
is all the dark squares are weak around
the black King and we are going to
exploit this with of a bishop pair now
to illustrate this I like to show you my
base game in this line where my opponent
continue with the Moon Knight to c6
hitting the e5 pawn
I played the move Bishop to g5 in other
words I am saying that nitrifiers not a
threat because I can always play the
move Queen to f6 my opponent responded
with the Moon Knight to e4 so
pressurizing the c3 square I continue
with the move Bishop to Webb 6 hitting
the rook and now there are few choices
for the black if black castles then this
is a blunder because after the move
Queen to e3 the queen is coming on at 6
with a devastation and if black captures
the e5 pawn then after Queen to f4
Knight captures and Bishop captures
black is simply exchange down so the
force apply over here is rook to g8
which is played by my opponent but now
black is really in difficult position
because his King will remain in the
center and this is the feature about
this game I continue with the move
Bishop to b3 my opponent plays Knight to
C Phi I play Queen to f4
my opponent captured the piece I
recapture now he played the move b6i
castle on the Kings side and after the
move Bishop to b6 I played the move c4
so completely blocking that bishop my
opponent plays Bishop to p7 I played
rook to d1 he played Queen to c5 so at
first sight it looks like nothing is
happening but
can you believe in just four moves black
resign I wonder if you can spot those
moves okay I hope you find this
continuation that is Queen to d2 hitting
the d7 ball so black has to forcefully
defend it with the move Bishop to CH and
now this amazing move Knight to c3 with
a very simple idea
so Knight wants to reach to the d6
square with a mate and in fact there is
no stopping black responds with the move
a six but after Knight to e4 he realized
that if he moves the Queen then there
will be a meet that's it guys I hope
with this brief analysis you are now
confident enough to meet this tricky
sniper opening remember the plan which I
have suggested throughout the video and
I think it will serve you very very well
the setup I have recommended in this
video is very easy to understand easy to
play and the most important part is it
not only give white a great deal of
advantage but it completely snaffle
sniper attacking ideas feel free to like
subscribe and comment on my video and
I'll meet you in my next lecture very
soon bye and take care
but White has a very good reply which is
taking the poll and calling the black
bluff
and of course black will take the pawn
so Bishop takes b2 and the big asset
from the black perspective is black has
the open F file and in some cases the
nasty sacrifices are looming there are
two good resources in the blumenfield
gambit